hey I'm just gonna test my internet
speed live for you because I've just cuz
I'm curious now to see what my internet
speed is after I've done a little
tweaking Safari here so here I'm using
Safari for WebKit also running a few
notepad documents and a screen recorder
as well as an email client and Skype so
my CPU is a little busy but we'll see
what kind of speeds will get mm-hmm
first we're gonna test Network 13 makes
a second 12 12 and 1/2 13 13 megabytes a
second so that's good download speed my
upload speed is like sand crabs yeah 1.5
makes a second so that's pretty decent
using the optimal online I'm going to
test two more times here so test got
decent results and that's gonna load up
all the servers again fade out and it'll
tell me my results so now I'm going to
go to test again at speedtest.net
now I'm going to test up the server
right closer to me into New Jersey much
lower latency there and it's called
fortress ITX and also getting big bad
down those seeds speed scuse me but what
I want to show you is my first of all my
results the fastest downloads I've
gotten I think I've showed you got 486
megabytes per second and I've also
gotten 6335 etc and the fastest upload
speed I've gotten is 2.3 megabytes per
second so 2.4 actually so I want to show
you guys is this a cool thing when you
go to my summary it's telling me that
I'm faster than ninety percent 97
percent of the global connections in the
world my average is also obviously not
very high but my best is 86 megabytes
per second new jersey average is
megabytes per second so that just tells
you how how incredible my isp is and
then you go to global stats and they're
pretty clean you can also search just in
your in your town alone who has the
fastest connection so I'm going to go to
North America say I want to you as a
fast
action in New York so I'm just gonna go
to Aftergood in the United States and
I'll go to New York and I'll just search
New York City who has a fastest
connection in New York City New Jersey
and New York shows these stats and
apparently I was in New York City I
would want to live in my hospital and
get in 30:39 megabytes per second
internet access of course I would not
want to live in that hospital but yeah
that's download results uploaders are a
little different however a little slower
so yeah
colleges are along I have won some of
the fastest internet connections yeah I
just thought it was cool that I had I
have a faster internet connection 97% of
the world thanks for watching subscribe
peace